obrigado então isso aqui vai ser uma
apresentação de razão cheia de emoção
como vocês vêem e nesse momento aqui
hoje o ponto mais alto meu currículo
certamente servir de referência para ana
que juntou esse povo maravilhoso aqui
discutindo idéias compartilhando
histórias né
então estou muito orgulhosa de fazer
parte desse evento hoje ea minha
pergunta que pra vocês é eu queria saber
se não causa estranheza pra vocês que
orientações médicas eu que sou médica se
modificam de ano a ano né com tanta
freqüência
eu porque seria que isso acontece e eu
vou começar contando uma história pra
vocês
para tentar explicar do meu ponto de
vista e compartilhar então com vocês
essa ideia vou começar contando a
história de uma vitamina a vitamina e
vitamina a e era reconhecida pelas suas
propriedades antioxidantes e se
acreditava que ela poderia inclusive
prevenir as doenças do coração e foi
isso que um estudo de observação no
início da década de 90 demonstrou as
pessoas que tinham alto consumo de
vitamina e na sua dieta
tinha uma freqüência uma incidência
menor de infarto em 1996 foi realizado
um ensaio clínico estudo com um grupo de
homens com doença cardiovascular que
recebeu suplementação de vitamina e
através de uma pílula e foi comparado
com outro grupo de homens semelhantes
o grupo controle que recebeu só percebo
uma pílula de farinha resultado a
vitamina e reduziu em quase 50% o risco
de infarto
uau a vitamina e tornou-se realmente
poderosa e 1997 44% dos cardiologistas
norte-americanos já receitavam
rotineiramente a vitamina e aos seus
pacientes
entretanto vários ensaios clínicos
posteriores não conseguiram reproduzir
os benefícios cardiovasculares da
suplementação de vitamina e daquele
primeiro
estudo em 1996 e finalmente em 2005 uma
revisão de 19 trabalhos publicados na
literatura médica com 135 mil pacientes
concluiu que na verdade o altas doses de
vitamina e aumentava a mortalidade e seu
uso deveria ser abandonado
você certamente conhece outras histórias
semelhantes com outros medicamentos e
até outras vitaminas seus membros da
vitamina c
poderíamos aqui escrever um tratado
sobre a ascensão e queda da vitamina c
quanto os medicamentos são lançados como
a melhores ou mais eficazes ou com menos
efeitos colaterais no mercado para mais
adiante não se mostrando em melhores que
medicamentos anteriormente disponíveis e
toda semana estudos contraditórios são
publicadas a respeito da associação de
um alimento com uma determinada doença
sem nunca chegar a uma conclusão
específica será que os estudos joão mal
conduzidos ou não controlados
isso até pode acontecer e fazer com que
se mude de opinião mas não parece ser o
caso aqui se nós fôssemos fazer uma
revisão da nata da pesquisa clínica
publicada em revistas científicas de
prestígio chamadas de alto impacto
vamos ver que apenas 44% ou menos da
metade dos estudos tiveram seus
resultados reproduzidas dos outros 14%
foram contrariadas por estudos
posteriores
outros 14% mostravam resultados
inflacionados e 24% não tinha sido nunca
posto à prova
o método científico deveria ser na
verdade a melhor forma de testar a
efetividade de uma teoria eu tenho uma
hipótese ou uma ideia desenvolvo método
para testar essa hipótese fácil estudo
conforme planejado e conclui
baseada em evidências se a hipótese e se
sustentou não é assim que a ciência a
medicina eo nosso conhecimento
sobre a natureza se desenvolve o que
estaria acontecendo então seria fraude
é provável também que não fraude
deliberada em ciência é muito pequena
estima se que por volta de 0,01 por
cento e jamais explicaria a profusão de
resultado de estudos que depois não são
comprovados
o que então pois é parece que a resposta
está na atual forma de financiamento e
publicação da pesquisa antes científica
as revistas científicas e os próprios
pesquisadores priorizam os resultados
positivos
então quanto mais positivo o resultado
mais chance deve ser publicado numa
revista de alto impacto
vou dar um exemplo para vocês o sd aqui
agência norte americana que regula os
ensaios clínicos entre 1987 e 2004
registrou 74 estudos sobre a eficácia de
antidepressivos 51% dos estudos 38 foram
positivos a favor dos antidepressivos
destes todos menos 137 foram publicados
e o que aconteceu com os outros 36
estudos que apresentaram resultados
negativos desses só três foram
publicados como tal 22 jamais saíram da
gaveta e ou se deles foram publicados
mas com uma análise diferente da
prevista para mostrar resultados também
positivos
raciocine agora comigo se eu tiver um
paciente eu sou médica vocês ouviram o
miguel que falar e se eu tiver um
paciente estiver pensando em tratá-lo
com o antidepressivo
eu penso que sou uma boa médica
vou fazer uma revisão de literatura o
que vou encontrar 48 estudos a favor do
antidepressivo e apenas três contrários
então vou lá resolvi tratar meu paciente
e na verdade eu estou sendo enganada o
meu paciente sendo enganado porque eu só
tive
o acesso à metade da informação
disponível sobre aquele ou melhor a
metade da informação sobre aquele
medicamento não estava disponível
é difícil é muito difícil da gente
entender o que acontece na ciência
porque acontece na nossa sociedade
também
nós privilegiamos só o sucesso
na verdade apesar de que cada um de nós
saiba no seu íntimo que nós aprendemos
muito mais com os erros do que com os
acertos
entretanto essa mais-valia aplicada a
ciência tem um efeito desastroso é um
sistema em que só merece ser publicados
aqueles trabalhos positivos cria um
sistema de incentivo que é perigoso
então será que com essa história que eu
contei pra vocês é possível
na verdade manipular dados porque o que
acontece é que no nosso no nosso sistema
de análise científica
muitas vezes a análise não é consensual
existe mais de uma maneira de fazer a
análise de dados e por exemplo se eu
tenho uma uma análise a que foi prevista
para desenvolver uma determinada
pesquisa e avaliar os resultados e as
análises por negativa e se eu tiver uma
outra análise análise b que não foi
planejada mas que tiver um resultado
significativo ou não um cientista pode
resolver publicar análise b que é
positivo em detrimento da área que foi
inicialmente planejada usa muito cento
os estudantes aprendi que eles precisam
contrapor à busca da verdade a pressão
para publicar
então existe um jargão acadêmico que a
vala publicar ou morrer do inglês
publiçor pérez e é isso que dizer que
pra defender sua tese o estudante
precisa publicar lá e ele só vai ter
sucesso
caso se os seus resultados foram
estatisticamente significativo
isso acontece também com os
pesquisadores mais graduados né eles
precisam publicar os seus trabalhos em
revistas científicas de prestígio não só
para reconhecimento pessoal mas também
para obterem financiamento para suas
pesquisas e só vão ter êxito né na
verdade se os seus resultados forem
positivos e impactantes e o que dizer da
indústria farmacêutica certamente terá
altos lucros se conseguir demonstrar que
o medicamento no seu portfólio é eficaz
tanto é que aquelas pesquisas clínicas
patrocinados pela indústria farmacêutica
tem uma chance
quatro vezes maior de demonstrar um
resultado positivo de um medicamento do
patrocinador do que outros estudos
independentes e será que quando um
cientista horta puro ou pesquisador
optar por uma análise que é benéfica
será que isso representa uma uma é uma
atitude mal intencionada priori é
provável que não os cientistas assim
como qualquer um de nós gostaria de ver
sua hipótese é comprovada é e tem uma
tendência a fazer um tipo de análise é
do seu estudo que mostre um resultado
positivo como será então que a gente
resgata a confiabilidade na ciência
biomédica
vocês vão ver que a solução é complexa
mas já existe em algumas atitudes ou
iniciativas que tomam corpo
uma delas é procurar a exigir dos órgãos
como fd a que eles disponibilizam os
protocolos de estudos que registram bem
como todos os dados porque a gente possa
comprovar ao verificar que a análise dos
resultados foi feito conforme o
planejado
outra idéia é estimular que todo estudo
publicado em revistas científicas seja
sistematicamente replicado ou
reproduzido
nós precisamos também de outras
plataformas
armas para divulgar trabalhos
científicos ea internet é uma delas onde
os cientistas poderiam publicar os seus
trabalhos com resultados negativos ou
menos impactantes e também
disponibilizar os dados brutos os seus
estudos para que sejam avaliados por
outros pesquisadores independentes seria
uma maneira de reduzir né os prejuízos
do do viés de publicação da manipulação
de dados que nós comentamos
anteriormente algumas revistas
científicas hoje já começam a registrar
trabalhos antes que sejam coletados
usados com o compromisso de é de
publicar os estudos né
sejam quais forem os resultados é isto
vai ajudar é uma mudança no paradigma de
publicação tradicional onde geral os
trabalhos são avaliados só depois de
finalizados
então é preciso que acho que nós
consigamos criticar e se esse sistema
onde o quando cada um busca a todo custo
o resultado positivo pra publicar ou
para ter reconhecimento todos perdem
coletivamente é chamada tragédia dos
comuns é isso só se enfrenta por
renúncias individuais iniciativas
coletivas
começa aqui porque um dilema por exemplo
como da preservação do planeta passa a
pelo mesmo tipo de solução
então eu acho que aqui assim como a arte
à ciência imita a vida pelo menos aquela
retratada por fernando de pessoal
fernando pessoa nos dois primeiros
versos do seu poema em linha reta
nunca conheci quem tivesse levado
porrada
todos os meus conhecidos têm sido
campeões em tudo
os cientistas são na verdade reticentes
em discutir a confiabilidade da pesquisa
científica com o público leigo e
entende-se no mundo como o nosso fugido
durante junho pelo fundamentalismo e por
dogmas a de toda espécie
a defesa do método científico sempre foi
e continua sendo uma prioridade
entretanto é preciso que nós não
entendamos os resultados de artigos
científicos como um outro dogma desfazer
ou desconstruir o mito dos
científicamente comprovado é importante
para que a a ciência possa refletir
sobre sobre ela mesmo e também se
mostrar aberta há questionamentos não
para ser infalível mas para poder
diminuir os erros que inevitáveis que
acontecem assim como qualquer um de nós
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]